Wow. I love this.
I'm thrilled.
The presentation was created by wired.
We've quantified your digital footprint so that you can see the impact you've
had on the internet. Oh, that's cool. That's neat.
I wonder what it means.
This is what happens when you Google the try guys. All right.
That's too many, three very common words. It does not surprise me.
1 billion. 540 million. Wait.
Yeah. Yeah. And it only took
0.71 seconds to find that money, Google, you sure are a trial.
It looks like the first video that pops up is the try guys.
Try Korean snacks for the first time I conic on exactly.
Not especially a big head. Yeah.
Or that bright and next the track guys try to make pants without
instructions.
S one of our favorite recent videos without instruction series.
It's about us doing things without instruction.
We like to try guys without blank titles that need to be very literal for
us. It writes itself. There's a track. I was Wiki. Wow.
We have a Wiki and it's not even just about feet. That's awesome. Wow.
That's huge for it. I had no idea that existed.
I have no idea what could be in the Wiki.
It's probably just that we said one section that comes up is people also ask
what happened to the try guys.
So it was a terrible plane crash when it happened to us. I need to know.
Are the track guys really friends? No. With others,
friends doesn't even begin to describe who we are. We're friends with benefits.
I'd say we like to think of ourselves more as brothers,
because friends get into arguments and split up brothers,
get into arguments and stay together. Brothers don't have a choice. Yeah.
I was adopted who is the most popular try guy? You know,
like it's hard to say who Eugene? Yeah. Quantifiably,
Eugene and qualitatively Eugene.
He has a lot more Instagram followers.
I like to think of myself as the most popular. Anyway.
That's what I like to think. Who started the track guys?
Technically the four of us did it together.
I'd say the most common misconception is that, uh, we were cast together,
but we, it was a self-made thing.
We found each other and it was really actually like,
I think you could say the audience created the try guys. We made a video.
It worked. They asked for more. Here we are. That's right.
Who created the track? Guys? You, you did baby. Oh God.
This is a Google trends. Graph of the try guys searched over time. A,
B and C three points here. What do we think?
A is probably the start of us like date. Oh, you know what though?
I bet you that's our motherhood series because like you see the beginning of the
try. Oh yeah. So AI is going to be our motherhood series.
B is probably when we launched our new company and our new channels.
And then C has to be our summer of try where a whole bunch of
things happened. We went on a 20 city tour.
Eugene released a music video coming out called I'm gay.
We also, uh, released our book, the hidden power of effing up.
I mean,
it was just like the biggest wildest summer of our lives and a podcast
and podcast overdue for another spike.
No steady decline per Google image search.
Here are some other words associated with the try guys,
Speedo with a photo backseat in target.
That's definitely key. I got a freak tongue,
baby aesthetic. I am aesthetic.
Thank you testosterone.
We did a very controversial testosterone tests. It was very funny. Actually.
Any testosterone searches are from, uh, outright trolls. I love that size.
Wow. Yeah. I'm telling you, man,
there was a huge soy boy moment where they were trying to use us to prove a
feminization of garbage. And I, you know, come out of hell.
We try to combat toxic masculinity through our videos and our work.
Sometimes people who are toxic try and fight back.
I'll say we don't care. Yeah. We don't care. Yeah. Look,
I think with everything that we do,
we try to show that there is no one right way to be a man to be a person.
Uh, and yeah, you can still be tiny and delicate and cute and still be awesome.
You can be big and suck a magic mic.
Yes, I do. Resemble Channing Tatum from the face down. Honestly,
if you read all of these together, it sounds like a Madlibs for bad porn.
We searched Reddit for the try guys. And these were some of the top results.
Can we guess what they are based on the name of the sub Reddit R slash beauty
guru chatter. Hm.
I think this one is we recreated some UT gurus,
iconic looks. So I bet that
you said that kind of say you're like, like a Euro meets a guru.
[inaudible] there we go. Beauty guru. Well, you're right man.
Yeah. Right.
We went on eBay and found the least expensive and most expensive items when
searching the try guys. I have no idea what they could be.
And even though we were on eBay,
there's some knockoff like these knockoffs or are these like maybe someone is
selling like a signed hoodie from the tour or something? Yeah.
They could be very excited. Let's see what the starting bid is. $200,
$200, probably like a signed hoodie as a signed copy of our book.
Ah, Oh, I'm going to tell you what you're getting. You're overpaying for that.
We're still selling them. We still have them and they don't cost that much.
Let's try guys.com 50 bucks. They Google Keith Haber's burger.
And these were some results. There's only 305,000.
That feels like drastically less than billions. Let's see what we got.
That's still feels like a lot. So I'm worried that their star with me,
because I had the lowest number. Why did Keith Haber's burger leave worth it?
Everybody thinks they kicked me off the show. That's not true.
I had something else to do. I was very supportive of them. Everybody's like,
he's a Dick. I'm a Dick. I was very supportive. Old time.
Everyone was real mean to me about him. There's no reason. I never said why.
So Keith, you chose us over worth it. I did. And I forgot some sway.
Me ever since. Have you seen the graph? Oh,
here's some related image searches to me. I'm excited for that.
Keith Evansburg and funny face. What would you want? Is it it's the one that
yeah. No.
I think that might be the screenshot I took and I posted all over Twitter and I
was like, this is my new reaction means it's my favorite. Wow. Which I first,
I first was using his reaction to him on our text threads,
filtrated his Google search. Wow. It's a beautiful, funny.
It shakes me to my core spiritually. Ethically.
It is against God's designed here's some top Reddit search results for Keith
burgers sorted by relevance, dancing with the stars.
No way am I going to be on dancing with the stars? Who are you kidding me?
Let me dust off some moves.
When searching Amazon for Keith Harrisburg or you found the following products,
probably chicken sauce, chicken,
chicken sauce in the three pack on amazon.com. I have a line of hot sauces.
They're delicious. They're not too hot. Get yourself some burger sauce more.
They're just gonna say it. I think burger solves better.
I like the original better. It's great on eggs.
It's great on sausage grid on pizza. It's great on everything, but you know,
I'm a big ranch boy. We Googled Nan Fullmer and these were some results.
People also ask about me. What is Ned? Farmer's real name?
Ned Fulmer. No, no, my,
I mean maybe they're asking what is my real name?
My real name is Edward med. That real name was Edward.
We were all shocked. So the core inside tri guys,
net Fulmars custom, California home from architectural digest.
My wife and I did a home renovation and to reveal it,
we were featured on architectural digest. She's very proud of it.
It's a huge deal. It's a big deal. I am also very proud of it.
Surprise pregnancy announcement to Wes Ned and Ariel.
We just had a new baby. Uh,
and when we found out about it, we told our son West, you know,
we have the try guys channel. I have a couple videos on my personal channel.
It's mostly surprise pregnancy announcements,
some related image searches for me. I Ned former. I don't know what this one is.
You have a very beautiful eye color. Oh thank you.
Maybe it's from that one picture of you where your eyes are, so, Oh yeah,
that must be it. How sometimes you smile for a photo,
but then the photo turns out and it doesn't really look right.
Full frontal flash me smiling like this Zach Kornfeld.
And these were some of the results,
409,000 to 2.1 second. So they really had to,
it's worked for that. Who was struggling,
not more keep looking this one's from Washington, post one,
a top of the box office during a pandemic film for free on zoom and then rent
out a theater. This is very exciting. Look,
we all have amazing talents and skills. However,
I am the only official movie star of the try guys. Yes.
I was the star of the number one movie in America. Uh, my buddy, Eric,
Dubach had this idea during the pandemic that since there were no new movies
coming out, we could film a movie,
rent out a theater and then just buy all the tickets again and again and again.
So he did that. Uh, and I think with $26,000,
it was the number one movie in America that week. Very exciting for me,
very depressing for the state of the movie industry.
I get to say forever that I was the star of the number one movie of America.
It's just one of the many things will Smith and I have in common,
we search Zach cornfield on Getty images. Can you tell us about these?
Oh yeah. This is me being the doggo and or gimp for poppy.
Poppy is a friend of ours. She is a wonderful, weird musician.
We were hosting the streamings and she came with us three leather bound
gimps she was walking them like they were dogs and she was backstage and she was
very sad. And I said, poppy, what's wrong? And poppy said, well,
the producers won't let me bring my gifts on stage. And I said, well,
poppy I'll do it. And she went really? And I'm like, yeah, I'm the host.
What are they gonna do? It's like, let's do this. They can't fire me.
We're in the middle of a show.
So she put a leash on my neck and I started walking out and I see the producers
go like, Nope. And then they kind of like, okay. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Then the following year they elected not to have it host. It was very weird.
I'm realizing, yeah. Like this alone should be the weirdest moment of my life.
I kind of forgot about it. I don't go myself very much.
I terrified of seeing what the internet has to say about Meg, as you know,
it's just not comfortable. So I really have no idea. What's gonna come up.
We Google the Eugene Liang and these were some results.
Well, 1.5 million because you put Eugene Liang and I'm gay.
Oh, perhaps,
maybe you don't think it's because we and yang are two of them. Oh yeah.
Maybe that's it. Maybe that's it.
The gene Leanne goes viral cost playing avatars in the last Airbender. Yeah.
I think there was actually a lot of press coverage. I wasn't aware of,
of my cost place. I did, uh,
Zuko Azula and Kyoshi from one of my favorites,
American animated series, and people loved it.
15 LGBTQ youth tubers, Brie Larson should collab with that.
That would be fantastic. Brie Larson is amazing. And she,
I believe started a YouTube channel, Eugene Liang movies and TV shows,
comfort girls. Uh,
so this was actually a short film I produced and it was part of a Asian
American film organization that I was a part of.
And it was an amazing short film. We've seen it. It's fantastic. It's cool.
He's very talented. I'm not a princess. Huh.
So that was actually a spec music video I made for the artists Marina
and the diamonds. Who's amazing. Self-funded it self cast. It choreographed.
It created this entire 12 minute video.
It was me reinterpreting old fairytales and turning the gender norms on their
heads. Here are some of the top Reddit search results for Eugene Liang sorted by
relevance. Ah, so this is my coming up video.
I still watch this video all the time.
Eugene Liang from Buzzfeed slash the try guys comes out as gay with a beautiful
choreography to one of my favorite Odessa songs posted to our slash
late bloomer lesbians. Well, I love that Reddit, uh, group.
We were going on a tour where my entire section was about being gay and I was
about to bring gay pride across the nation and not my whole family didn't know I
was gay, so I had to make something. And so I, uh,
basically was going to do it on my own. And then I was like,
why would I do this? Because we have a company. So I was like, okay,
I'll put it on the channel. And I did it within a month.
This was an interesting example.
And you'll probably see more of this in our documentary of my public life.
Especially as a video producer, uh, proceeding my private life.
And it sort of forced my hand.
And so I had to respond to it through my public work.
And so it was very emotionally difficult.
And I would say that in the end it was a great excuse to be able to come out to
some people I'm close to. But yeah, that's fantastic.
I really hope that anyone who still comes across this video in
you is moved by it or the old something from what I had to say in
the moment. And yeah,
I'm still incredibly proud of the conversation that it started.
I would not advise anyone publishing a multi-million view video to come out to
your parents, but,
but in the end it worked out really well because I think the impact also helped
people. I love show how important this is to an entire community.
So, you know, in the end it worked out,
we searched Eugene Liang or Getty images. Can you tell us about these images?
Oh, my this photo was actually from the first comedy show was ever part of and
Keith attended with did Becky. And, um,
it was basically storytelling from a lot of entertainers.
I actually thought it went pretty well. I had to,
I basically did like a country music redo of my childhood fun fact.
I really love country. Mm. Uh, such tall hair.
This was from the Asian Americans end of the year award show.
This was the first year I attended. I was honored with rakeout male star,
which was fantastic. This was, I think 2016,
but I was also honored alongside like Steven noon. And I mean,
there were actual stars there. I was just, I was just like little old me.
It was crazy because the Asian American community,
especially in Hollywood are very tight and we're all very supportive.
And this is my favorite award show to go to. Because after this,
I made this sort of the platform for me to really express a lot of my gender
style.
So the subsequent years I just got Geyer and gayer and
gayer and man do some of those old Asian guys not know what they're looking at,
but yeah, you knew I was strutting around and that was one of the years,
move on herself. Ming. Now,
when came out to me and said I was a gorgeous unicorn and I cried and I never
cry.
I was also very drunk cause they are also always sponsored by whiskey brands
because they are run by Koreans and we love whiskey.
I feel like that's a pretty good byline for you.
Most of the really gay and beautiful and also drunk that was true.
The internet can be a really divided place. It can be really brutal, scary,
and volatile, but we always try to put as much good in the world as we can.
I think a lot of these results proved that a lot of good comes back. Yeah.
I was surprised at how warm and nice a lot of those responses were maybe not the
soy testosterone stuff, but they didn't know.
They don't know how much we don't care about that. Thank you for having us wide.
We are the dry guys.
Go check out our movie and until next time get that graphite
or you gave it a try.